j'aimerais juste qu'on vienne de seconde
sur l'émission d'hier parce que voilà
vous n'avez vous n'étiez pas là et eux
et vous n'étiez pas là et je voudrais
remercier toutes les personnes qui ont
fait l'émission hier regardez toutes ces
personnes qui étaient là autour de la
table il y avait isaura yahvé venance y
avait-il dit la vessie ou d'abord
d'aller vers las vegas la ville
merci à eux
historique hier soir en vain
et c'est votre corps à vue pour appels
et vous avez fait le record historique
de tous par oswald ac c'est le record
voilà toutes cibles confondues 1 thierry
moreau c'est ils ont fait leur corps
voilà donc alors c'est parce que voilà
8,5 me et % de part de marché c'est le
record et 17,1 sur les ménagères sacs d
achat voilà c'était un carton voilà donc
merci à vous les chiffres et lorient il
avait choisi de pas venir
donc voilà ça vous fait du bien de
retrouver vos places oui oui vous avez
regardé l'émission d'hier
oui oui vous êtes j'ai pas trouvé que
l'émission était meilleure
[Rires]